So, now you have the keys to the castle,
and you've gotten the tour.
You may have noticed, there's kind of
an exclusive wing of the castle that
you do have to pay to get into.
Remember earlier, when we were talking
about predicted traffic time, and
certain features of the roads API?
We mentioned the Premium Plan.
The Premium Plan is a way for
businesses and users to get access to
some exclusive features of the API to
enable a larger amount of quota and
to get help from Google's
technical support team.
>> There are a few more things you
get if you become a Premium Plan
customer as well.
For example more repoints per request
in the direction service request.
More destinations and
origins in distance matrix.
Specific places API data,
not to mention generally higher
queries per second on the services.
And access to more usage analytics.
Check out the page link in
the instructor notes for
the exact usage limits, and
other data on the Premium Plan.
>> We're going to go through
a few situations where,
according to our terms of service, you
must purchase a license to use the APIs.
>> First, if you plan on using
the APIs on an internal domain,
that is not publicly available.
Like for example, if you are a delivery
service that wants to optimize routes
for your vehicles and
visualize them to run your business.
>> Another situation where you
would need to purchase a license
is if you plan on using the APIs
in some kind of paid service.
For example, if purchasing a product
gets the user access to a site
that uses the APIs or
if you have a cost to enter that site.
>> Finally,
if you plan on doing asset tracking.
That is, using the Google Map's APIs
to track one or
more physical objects,
you must be a Premium Plan customer.
>> Again, a general rule of thumb.
If your usage is free for
users, so no fee, and
publicly available to everyone,
no firewall,
you can use the plan available through
your developer project that you created.
Even if you go above the free limit and
enable pay as you go billing.
>> The page in the instructor notes
has more detailed information
about the Premium Plan benefits and
usage limits.
Now, on your own, take a look at some
more information about the ideas we've
talked about so far.